We ask for your protection over our school
and we pray that we will be kept from harm
throughout the night
Amen Amen
*singing* Shhhhh
Ms. Martha!
Ms. Martha!!
Is he dead?
No get him inside.
Quick!
You're a most unwelcome visitor
and we do not propose to entertain you.
You'll find that I'm easily amused.
You won't be here long enough for that.
How did you end up in this place?
Why are you so interested in me?
I admire your strength.
I'm just trying to give them what they need to survive in these times
If you have anything in the world what would it be?
To be taken far away from here
Come with me.
He seems to be a sensitive person.
Does he?
*giggles*
*gasp*
Nina!
John.
It seems the enemy is not what we believe.
Hope you like apple pie.
Is that my recipe?
It is.
*choking gasping*
I need rags.
I need chloroform.
Go to the smokehouse, get the saw, now.
Bring me the anatomy book
Can I get you anything?
Get me the key.
You know I'd get in trouble for that.
*scream*
AAARG What have you done to me????
You vengeful bitches.